A Quiet Place has triumphantly tiptoed into
theaters, enjoying critical acclaim as well
as success at the box office.
Director John Krasinski delivers a thriller
with a unique concept and a cleverly limited
set of cinematic tools.
Unlike most modern mainstream movies, it's
a film that relies less on spoken dialogue
than on ambient sounds, visuals, and mystery.
A Quiet Place introduces the Abbott family,
who try to survive on their secluded farm
after a worldwide invasion of creatures that
hunt by sound.
Getting by with a variety of creative sound-dampening
solutions and communicating with sign language,
they face the challenges of adolescence, guilt,
and even a pregnancy.
Their story builds to a climax that wraps
up the action while leaving a few questions
still unanswered.
If you want to know more about just what went
down in the final minutes, keep quiet and
check out our spoiler-filled rundown.
This the ending of A Quiet Place explained.
Rockets' red glare
In A Quiet Place's opening scene, youngest
child Beau proposes that a rocketship could
help the family escape.
His fascination with space travel proves to
be his downfall, as a toy shuttle in his hands
makes enough electronic noise to attract one
of the creatures.
His family watches helplessly as the boy is
snatched away just before the main title.
Beau's death informs the character arcs for
the rest of the story, as the film jumps ahead
a year and finds everyone struggling with
grief and guilt while attempting to maintain
some sense of normalcy under the oppressive
silence.
His memory plays a key role in the finale,
as the monsters move in on Evelyn Abbott when
she goes into labor.
Her husband, Lee and their son, Marcus draw
them away by putting into action a one-word
plan: "Rockets."
While the farm glows red with the warning
lights that signal an attack, a volley of
fireworks distracts the beasts and allows
Lee to take back the house and rejoin his
wife and newborn son.
Sacrificial scream
One of A Quiet Place's central plot threads
focuses on Lee and Evelyn's daughter, Regan,
and her strained relationship with her father.
As the one who gave Beau the toy that led
to his death, Regan thinks that Lee blames
her.
Lee's overprotective tendencies toward his
deaf daughter don't exactly help her feel
that he believes in her, either.
In one of the film's key scenes, Marcus reminds
his father that he needs to tell Regan how
much he loves her.
It is a huge emotional payoff, then, when
Lee rescues Marcus and Regan from a creature
and tells them that he has always loved them.
While the kids take shelter inside a pickup
truck with the beast clawing to get inside,
Lee lets out one final, anguished scream,
giving his life to save them as they throw
the truck into neutral and it rolls back to
the house.
It's a cathartic moment not only for the three
characters, but for the audience as well,
to break the silence with a tragic but triumphant
emotional release.
All ears
The greatest mystery of A Quiet Place remains
the creatures themselves.
Aside from some vague news headlines, there
is barely any exposition given about where
they come from or just how the invasion went
down.
For most of the film's runtime, the monsters
are glimpsed only briefly, appearing as fleeting
blurs or vague shapes.
The climax, however, finally reveals them
in all their gruesome glory as one of them
stalks Evelyn and her newborn baby into the
basement of the farmhouse.
They have eyeless heads that splits open in
all directions to expose sensitive hearing
membranes.
In addition to delivering a horrific visual,
this design explains the physiology that allows
the beasts to so accurately strike at even
the subtlest sounds.
Ferocious feedback
A unique aspect of A Quiet Place is its use
of American Sign Language to convey the vast
majority of the dialogue.
Krasinski chose to hire a deaf actress to
portray the hearing-impaired Regan for the
sake of authenticity, and he worked with her
to develop signing habits and styles that
informed each family member's attitude and
character arc.
The monsters' weakness is at last revealed
to be feedback, as the noise emitted from
Regan's cochlear implant when they are near
confuses their heightened sense and racks
them with pain.
During the final confrontation, Regan discovers
the pile of discarded custom boosted implants
that Lee had been working on, showing how
much he cared for her while also providing
her with the ability to fight back for the
first time.
Locked and loaded
Regan uses Lee's radio transmitter to amplify
the feedback, causing the intruder to recoil,
disoriented, and expose its inner membranes.
Evelyn takes the opportunity of having a clear
shot at this weak spot for the first time
and blows the thing away with her shotgun.
Naturally, this is the kind of loud sound
the Abbots have been avoiding, as Lee's security
monitors show the other two creatures known
to inhabit the area racing toward the farmhouse.
But Evelyn's ready this time and gives her
daughter a reassuring smile as she cocks the
shotgun and the movie cuts to credits, sending
the audience out of the theater without releasing
their adrenaline high.
The next generation
Evelyn's pregnancy and labor are a driving
source of tension for most of A Quiet Place,
and it's not just to harvest the audience's
anxieties.
A major theme of the film is the struggle
to survive and adapt to some kind of normalcy
in the midst of horrific societal changes.
That's why the invasion occurs before the
story begins and the rebellion against the
monsters is saved for after its ending.
Evelyn and Lee's newborn baby serves as a
symbol for the belief that life can go on.
Children will be born who never knew life
before the quiet.
"Who are we, if we can't protect them?"
Regan, Marcus, and the baby at their mother's
side in the film's final moments represent
what the story is all about: the future.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!